by joining us now author of Trump vs.
China facing America's greatest threat
of bestseller former House Speaker and
Fox News contributor Newt Gingrich so to
be a Democrat you have to reject all the
fairness that you provided the minority
party and fill Clinton and his attorneys
to be a Democrat you have to care about
foreign election interference with
Russia but not the dirty dossier to be a
Democrat you'd have to ignore the
Biden's quid pro quo and zero experience
hunter paid millions you have to have
you're a Democrat believe anybody that
made an accusation against Kavanagh but
ignore the accusations against the
lieutenant governor of the Commonwealth
of Virginia breathtaking hypocrisy mr.
speaker there's nothing in that
transcript that I see where the
President did anything wrong as a matter
of fact I'd argue he did the right thing
by faithfully executing the laws of this
country well there's no question that
the agreement made between President
Clinton and Ukraine requires the
president states to cooperate in
corruption fighting in Ukraine and in
that sense a lot of what Trump was doing
actually ironically is under the law
exactly what the president should be
doing but remember none of this is real
I mean what you're faced with here is a
democratic party desperately committed
to destroying the president they don't
care what the arguments are they don't
care what the facts are they have an
absolute deep passionate need I would I
would argue a pathological need to try
to destroy the president even if in the
process they themselves and so I
think all of us who try to talk about
facts misunderstand the conversation
this is a drama this is a drama and what
Schiff and Pelosi and others are living
out their fantasies largely out of
desperation because I think deep down
they think Trump's going to get
reelected and they're just faced with a
nightmare and so none of this stuff is
real people shouldn't judge it as real
because it's a theater and it's the
theater
of hate Trump led by Schiff and Pelosi
so they Limpy let's assume do you
believe they'll impeach the president
and if they do what should the Senate do
well I think they may you know I keep
watching and I do think the Republicans
have been effective and that's you know
I'm just asking the question indirectly
the witnesses did you see a crime no did
you see an impeachable offense no I mean
there's a point over the weight of that
I suspect there are a number of marginal
Democrats in districts of Trump carried
who would love for this all go away
because they know if the vote comes up
they're going to have to vote yes or
they'll be devoured by their own
activists but if they do vote yes
they're gonna be devoured by the pro
Trump base of their district so they're
really I think in a very very difficult
situation I think that McConnell has
reached a decision this is the sense I
get that they're going to go ahead and
have a trial and of course as you just
saw a Newman esterday announced earlier
this evening with Lindsey Graham
beginning to call in the inspector
general with other things starting to
develop right I don't know if I were a
Democrat if I'd be very happy with the
kind of open hearings the kind of
subpoenas that Lindsey Graham is likely
to have and then the kind of frankly
honest debate on the floor of the Senate
which will be I think deeply to the
disadvantage of Joe Biden and deeply to
disadvantage the Democratic Party what
is the impact sumi-e gets acquitted in
the Senate pretty short order federal
rules of evidence no hearsay allowed we
have the transcript I nobody that I know
sees anything wrong with the transcript
I don't think you do either
what impact is all of their actions for
the last three years and what we will
discover about abuse of power corruption
a systematic resistance to take down a
duly elected president what impact will
this all have by November of 2020 and
351 days well look I think the biggest
impact ironically
may be the destruction of the American
news media over 50% of the country now
sees the news media as
deliberately anti-trump having no
interest in the facts not covering the
news serving as a propaganda I've never
I'm in the news media today is weaker
than it's been at any time in my
lifetime and that ultimately is a huge
disadvantage for the Democrats because
the Democrats are in position where they
need the news media to be believable
excuse me and they're not believable
because the fact is that every day you
see the New York Times The Washington
Post MSNBC ABC doing things that only
work if it's propaganda yeah all right
mr. speaker I'll let you get a drink of
water we appreciate you being with us